i
ah
la asamblea nacional de sierra leona
decidió por unanimidad abolir la pena de
muerte lo cierto es que la última vez
que se ejecutó una sentencia de muerte
en sierra leona fue hace 20 años tras la
guerra civil pero la ley seguía vigente
en el código penal y se seguían
emitiendo a sentencias en 2020 aún había
99 personas en el corredor de la muerte
y la derogación de la pena de muerte en
sierra leona se produjo en un contexto
de movilizaciones sociales para la
supresión de las leyes coloniales aún
vigentes y la reforma del sistema
judicial promesas electorales en su día
también del actual presidente de la
republica julius mada envió y la
abolición de la pena de muerte en este
país se dan sintonía a los avances que
se producen en todo el continente
de las 54 naciones estados africanos
reconocidos internacionalmente hay 23
que ya han abolido totalmente la pena de
muerte entre los que cabe destacar los
casos recientes de malawi
y ahora también sierra leona
[Música]
china es el país que más reo se ejecuta
en el mundo es la estimación de las
organizaciones de derechos humanos
porque la cifra es un secreto de estado
sí que sabemos que se han reducido
drásticamente desde unas 20 mil hace 20
años a las actuales 2000 según los
cálculos de la fundación dui hua y eso
es porque china existido que sólo se
puede aplicar como último recurso ha
recortado el número de delitos que la
contemplan de 64 a 46 y desde el 2011
obliga a que las sentencias
condenatorias dictadas por los
tribunales provinciales sean refrendadas
por el tribunal supremo- en asia la otra
gran potencia japón también aplica la
pena de muerte
además de una forma que es calificada
por muchos como de torturas psicológicas
ya que los reos pueden estar durante
años esperando la ejecución que sólo les
es comunicada esa misma mañana lo que
les conduce a unos comprensibles cuadros
de estrés y ansiedad en el sudeste
asiático países como vietnam indonesia o
tailandia recurren a la pena de muerte
en su lucha contra el narcotráfico
[Música]
a julio del 2021 la pena de muerte en
eeuu es legal en 27 estados y en el
gobierno federal y es prohibida en 23
estados incluyendo el distrito de
columbia donde está washington virginia
que era el estado con más ejecuciones
después de texas prohibió la pena de
muerte este año y recientemente también
lo hicieron estados como colorado y new
hampshire desde 1976 se han ejecutado a
1.534 personas y en este momento hay en
la fila de muerte dos mil quinientas 33
personas sin embargo muchos estados en
los que todavía es legal la pena de
muerte han puesto moratorias para
suspender las ejecuciones
además las sentencias de muerte también
se han reducido sustancialmente por
ejemplo en el en 1998 se sentenciaron
285 personas mientras que el año pasado
se sentenciaron 18 las inyecciones
letales son la forma más común para
efectuar estas ejecuciones pero se han
usado también en eeuu desde 1976
paredones ahorcamientos electrocuciones
y cámaras de gas
[Música]